you cannot talk about a story without
talking about the underlying moral
message that story is built upon this
goes for any major piece of literature
theater or cinematography and one piece
with its complex web of characters and
ideologies is no exception to this one
of the most central moral themes that is
thoroughly explored in one piece is
justice it's a golden thread that spans
throughout the entire story what does it
mean to be just what rules does it imply
and who decides what these rules are we
explore these questions through the
characters we encounter throughout the
story and even more so through the
actions that these characters then take
based on their distinct beliefs we
follow a main character that despite
being a pirate often acts a lot more
justly than many of the supposedly good
Marines and with the Revolutionary Army
Oda has even introduced an entity in the
story that openly opposes an idea of
justice under which large parts of the
world are suffering however in no other
context is the concept of justice
explored as openly indistinctly as
within the ranks of the Marine Admirals
each Admiral has a unique perspective
and take on what justice means for them
and as a consequence each Admiral
impacts the story in very different ways
in this series we will take a closer
look at the four Marine Admirals that we
know of so far and explore together what
the different ideas of justice truly
mean and how they express themselves in
the context of one piece and what better
candidate to start with than the coolest
of the four and get it the coolest never
mind
Kuzon or as he's better known al ki g is
probably the Admiral that we have gotten
the most complete picture of so far next
to his amazing design and his unique del
food power
okichi follows the path of lazy justice
but how exactly can justice be lazy and
how does it distinguish him from his
fellow admirals if you've ever wondered
about that no worries that's why we here
today before we get into the moral
structure of Coos ins character though I
first want to quickly update you guys on
our small challenge we've had recently
once again you have
bb2 it and reached a 3,000 light mark on
the last video a lot faster than I
anticipated to shape so this time we're
gonna raise the bar to 3,500 likes in
the very first 24 hours that this video
is online and you will get the second
Admiral by next Tuesday and by the way
if you're wondering why in the world is
this guy trying to get more likes on his
videos it's because one it makes these
videos a lot more available to more
people and two it really motivates me
like crazy to work more consistently to
give you guys not only more but also
better content so smash the like button
and make me work but enough about that
after all we're here to delve into one
of the most philosophical questions in
the entirety of storytelling so let's
take a look at the man who is so chill
that he thinks justice should be lazy
okichi cruisin is one of the most
popular members of the Marines that most
of the time acts as an antagonistic
force to Luffy and his crew he's a tall
slender and muscular Lee build man with
long curl back hair and tan skin despite
being the youngest among the admirals by
quite a bit he nonetheless is without a
doubt one of the strongest characters in
the story thanks to years of hard
training as well as his powerful logia
devil fruit that turns his entire body
into ice having joined the ranks of the
Marines at a very young age
Alki G has worked his way up the ranks
fairly quickly which is no big surprise
as we know he can be very determined and
focused when he needs to in general
however alka G is a rather laid-back
person that enjoys respect and
popularity throughout the ranks of the
Marines this is most likely not only due
to his immense strength and influence
but also due to his personality which is
unusually kind and respectful compared
to other high-ranking members as a
matter of fact respect and fairness are
two of the most defining traits for
qoodles personality not only does he
treat his fellow Marines respectfully
and fair but he even acknowledges
alleged criminals for doing good deeds
a great example for this is letting
luffy and the crew go free
not only for taking down the tyrannical
crocodile and liberating alabasta but
also out of respect for Luffy's will to
sacrifice himself for his crew what
makes our ki ji a truly good character
in the eye of the reader however is that
his respectfulness and fairness are
firmly grounded in the empathy and
compassion he feels for others he takes
people circumstances and their good
intentions into account and wants to
help create a world with less suffering
and pain we can see this for instance
when he freezes the entire ocean only to
let on she'd returned to his clan after
the events at the Davi back fight but I
think nothing proves this point quite as
well as his relationship with Robin even
though he was tasked with tracking her
down and capturing her he was genuinely
relieved and happy that she had finally
found true friends all of that despite
the straw hats just having invaded
Anna's Lobby and having declared war
against the world government itself
okichi however is very aware of Robins
true personality and how she had no
fault at becoming a criminal in the eyes
of the world which is exactly why he
allowed her to flee the slaughter of her
Island many years ago in the first place
you may ask yourself now how someone
this caring and apparently soft could
possibly become an admiral in the
otherwise so hard-boiled Marines as a
matter of fact many of the Marines asked
themselves the same question but the
answer to that is quite simple Kuzon has
an incredibly strong sense of duty even
though he allows himself to live
according to his morals most of the time
when it's expected of him he's always
ready to follow orders and do what's
expected of him as an admiral during the
war at marine fort for example he
grudgingly drops his usually laid-back
and friendly nature and trades it for a
more
an unforgiving personality and we can
also see this when he first encounters
Robin and the straw heads for the first
time where he had first decides to leave
them alone before changing his mind and
trying to take Robin only to flip-flop
once again after seeing Luffy stand up
for her what becomes painfully clear
when we look at this example is how
conflicted Alka ji is between his own
idea of how to act morally and his duty
as a member of the Marines and the world
government as you might have suspected
all of this also plays a decisive role
in his sense of justice so now in order
to understand what lazy justice actually
means let's have a look at al-qaeda's
character arc to understand what Kooza
means when he talks about his lazy
justice we first have to understand how
his character has developed over the
course of the story
despite the admirals not exactly getting
a lot of screen time in the story Alka G
has nonetheless undergone a significant
change of perspective as a base for that
we have to look at the Admiral in his
younger days where he was actually still
a Vice Admiral to be more precise even
we have to look at the events
surrounding the destruction of the
island of O'Hara back in time okichi had
a very different take on justice in
general when first informed about the
events on the island by his men he
doesn't really care about the fate of
the islands for him it is simply the
deserved fate of criminals that have to
be taken out to protect the peace he
only changes his mind when he learns
that his old friend Jaguar D Seoul who
previously had deserted the Marines to
save Robins mother Livia is also on Hara
when arriving on the island he appears
indifferent to the injustice that is
happening there in the name of the world
government and at first
Kuzon decides to follow his sense of
duty and takes down his old friend Saul
himself who was trying to escape with
the young Robin when Saul confronts him
about the massacre going on
okichi says that he is actually no real
opinion about it but we can already read
from this response that he's not at all
happy with what is happening
just a short time later however he has
to witness a canoe sinking a ship full
of refugees simply on the whim that some
of the scholars might have sneaked on
board this seems to be the decisive
turning point for him it becomes very
clear that al-qaeda indeed did have an
opinion about what was happening and he
decides to let the innocent girl Robin
escape the island what this shows us is
that how kg has always been good at
heart but forcefully has put his duty
before his own ideals he needed to
realize the gruesome lengths to which
the world government would go to protect
its power and he also needed to learn
how to put his own morality into his
actions as well and distance himself
from the justice practiced by the
higher-ups this is what the incident of
O'Hara was all about for his character
so now we know how out qiji got to
follow his path of lazy justice but we
still don't quite know what lazy is
actually supposed to mean in this
context as a matter of fact lazy can be
seen in quite a variety of ways when it
comes to justice I would argue that Alka
G labels his justice as lazy to
distinguish himself from his fellow
Admiral a kinda well the kind of
absolute justice leaves no room for
interpretation and situation based
morality coozes justice is lazy in the
sense that it is not always necessary to
take action no matter what sometimes it
might be the right thing to take a look
at things first and see how they develop
this is exactly what we see him doing
most of the time observing but not
taking action unless he sees a truly
justifiable reason for it but even more
so than that I would argue that with the
phrase lazy LKG is actually hiding his
true idea of Justice which is moral
justice when we strip away all the
distractions around his character at his
core al Qaeda's idea of justice is based
on his values in other words compassion
respect and fairness
since this very liberal take on the
issue conflicts heavily with that of the
world government how
Kuzon can use his laziness as an excuse
to actually take moral action in
critical situations while most people
will feed as him being lazy and
undetermined alkie ji is actually able
to make himself a clear image of the
situation he then can assess whether
someone deserves respect or compassion
and what the fair and right thing to do
is this allows him to let Robin go on a
Hara letting the straw heads get away
after the Devi back fight or letting
Luffy off the hook several times during
marine fort not dealing the fatal blow
or chasing after law submarine and even
when he tries to uphold his sense of
duty towards the Marines we can always
see a glint of mercy and understanding
in his actions even though it is quite
unique in the ranks of the Marines
Kuzon believes in second chances and he
usually gives people the benefit of
doubts seeing how he actually cares for
Robin and feels responsible for what
happened to her in the past really shows
us how different our ki ji is from his
superiors which is exactly why I believe
that in the end he went his own way
after having to kill one of his closest
friends on ohhara and swallowing his
morality during the war Kuzon decided to
change something he plans on turning the
Marines into a more compassionate and
positive organization that works for the
people after being suggested as the new
Fleet Admiral by sangoku himself being
defeated by a Cano during the duel
however he saw no purpose in continuing
his work as an admiral instead he now is
free to act based on his own idea of
justice freed from any restriction or
doubt now the question here of course is
whether al-qaeda is actually still a
marine at heart or not currently he
seems to be affiliated with the
Blackbeard pirates in some shape or form
however after being saved by him from
doflamingo smoker as okichi who he is
now but the former Admiral reassures his
friend that as a matter of fact he is
still himself well does he mean by that
that he's still a Marine possibly but
most importantly I think that al-qaeda
is still himself in the sense that he's
a man of his own justice
someone who now is able to follow his
own path of moral justice and it's okay
if two others it looks like it is lazy
after all al ki ji is a pretty cool dude
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did make sure to smash that like
button for a freshly made video next
Tuesday and subscribe if you aren't
already part of the crew also I asked
you last time to come up with an
alternative title for body and I was
happy to see so many creative ideas in
the comments this time I will give the
wind to buggy D clown which is just too
good not to pick and since there were
multiple entries of this idea I can't
just stayed one winner in particular but
amazing job everybody this one is truly
perfect for next week I'm super curious
to see what title you can come up with
for our man out ki ji finally if you
want to learn more about the characters
in one piece you can simply click here
and make yourself a great one peace day
otherwise I see you guys around next
time and until then have a wonderful
week